dominic cummings now finds himself as an
outsider
no longer at the heart of an operation
he helped to settle
do you have any reports it was a very
public departure for mr cummings
who apparently ran his department with
an iron fist
he was said to be seemingly all-powerful
but evidently not untouchable
the the shelf life of advisors is time
limited
and the more controversial the advisor
the more limited that
shelf life is and it's an actual time
for dominic cummings to move on
he's a very prickly character dominic
cummings
is is a dragon slayer and the problem is
that when the dragons no longer with us
you don't need a dragon slayer anymore
and we need a different sort of
government now
the prime minister surrounded himself
with the architects of the leave
campaign
and some fear the departure of mr
cummings could be a sign that the prime
minister might be poised to loosen his
stance on brexit
although downing street says britain's
negotiating position
remains unchanged ever since boris
johnson walked through the doors of
downing street dominic cummings has been
by his side
he's been his closest aid and confidant
wielding huge influence over policy and
big decisions
but what makes this all the more seismic
is that there's an awful lot coming over
the horizon in the next few weeks and
months
brexit the pandemic and for the first
time boris johnson will be without
his infamous right hand man the question
is whether things will be different now
if we
accept that dominic cummings's departure
makes the pm a completely new person are
we saying that the pm
was his puppet that the pm was
completely incapable
of making his own decisions i i just
don't
see this the prime minister of the prime
minister the decisions that the buck
stops with him there's no doubt that
something
big has happened inside government but
this is being seen as an opportunity
to get more harmonious perhaps more
effective government
at a testing time for britain nick
martin sky news